thank you to ancestry for supporting pbs
you're relaxing at home when there's a
knock on the door you peer through the
peephole and see a small child with
their hoodie obscuring their face
you open your door and ask if they need
help but when they look up
you are staring into black lifeless eyes
it's not hard to figure out why these
creatures horrify us so much
it's in their name black-eyed children
or black-eyed kids
also known as bek are modern monsters
whose eerie and unnatural appearance and
behavior inspire
fear the unusual eyes are unnerving
but it's the age of these monsters that
really amps up the terror
what is it about evil children that
freaks us out so
much i'm dr emily zarka
and this is monstrum the first report of
a black-eyed kid
appeared in 1998. texan reporter brian
bethel wrote of an experience he had two
years prior
while he was sitting in his car near a
movie theater bethel claimed that his
car was approached by two boys around
the ages of 9 and 12 wearing hooded
sweatshirts
one appeared as an olive-skinned
curly-headed young man and the other
a red-headed pale-skinned freckled young
man
bethel opened the window a crack and the
two boys asked for a ride to their
mother's house to pick up some money so
they could see the mortal kombat movie
to this day bethel recalls that when the
second one of the boys spoke
he felt an unnatural sense of dread he
pointed out the movie had already
started and they wouldn't make it back
in time
but the boys began to push harder saying
things like
they were just two kids and that they
didn't have a gun or anything
bethel describes their voices as
mechanical and rehearsed
the strange experience culminated in
terror when he realized each boy had
black
eyes soulless orbs with no white showing
at all
understandably unnerved he began to
drive away but one of the boys banged on
his window and angrily cried
we can't come in unless you tell us it's
okay let us in
bethel sped off and upon checking his
rear rear-view mirror he noted that the
strange black-eyed children had
completely vanished
in 2013 bethel wrote that his strange
experience with these children was
originally shared in a private
communication
with a small group of friends on email
list that then was leaked onto the
internet
i couldn't find any evidence of this
original document
but bethel's story is undoubtedly the
foundation of all bek lore
and that's how an urban legend is born
in eyewitness accounts and other stories
the child-like creatures are frequently
wearing hooded clothing
although some versions claim they are
dressed in antiquated outfits
they have odd speech patterns black eyes
and perhaps most
importantly they just don't act in a way
we think children
should similar to some vampire legends
it appears that they must be invited
into a private space
and to me this creepiness evokes fairy
demon and changeling vibes
though encounters tend to end without
lasting effects some people who've had
run-ins with these creatures report
nightmares and agoraphobia
through the numerous interviews bethel
conducted as his story circulated online
others across the world began to speak
up about their own supposed experiences
with other black-eyed children
england in particular seems plagued by
black eyed children
and they often serve as fodder for
tabloid magazines and newspapers
like in 2014 when songwriter and
paranormal investigator lee brickley
was interviewed by the birmingham mail
about the sighting in canuck chase
england
the sensational story was quickly picked
up by the british and international
press
brickley had been investigating rumored
sightings of a black-eyed ghost and
canik chase
including one where a woman and her
daughter were out for a walk when they
heard
screams and spotted a child wandering
alone the mother ran to catch up but
could not find the child
when she turned back around a girl
appearing to be 10 years old stood there
with her hands
over her eyes she asked are you okay
were you screaming
the girl just dropped her hands and
revealed eyes the woman said were
completely black
no iris no white startled the woman
grabbed her daughter and jumped
back when she looked up expecting to see
the child
she'd vanished interestingly brickley
also claimed
the same girl whom he calls a ghost had
been seen 30 years earlier in 1982 in
that same
area by his own aunt something he wrote
about in his 2013 book
ufos werewolves and the pig man brickley
claims that his aunt heard a child
crying at night
and following the sobs she came upon a
girl about six years old
who looked up at her with completely
black eyes before racing off into the
woods
even a police search for the child
turned up nothing
the sightings of the singular female bek
and kanik chase
may be connected to a real-life tragedy
that influenced brickley's
identification of the creature as a
ghost
kinnick chase made headlines in the
1960s as the site of one of the largest
police investigations in british history
the search for the murderer of three
local school girls
some say the black-eyed child of that
area is the ghost of one of the girls
and it would make sense that a young
female resident who grew up with those
stories
would believe that she had seen
something even if it wasn't there
as the urban legend of the black eyed
children evolved out of references to
eyewitness accounts of the monsters in
the british and american press
their presence across media of all kinds
exploded
numerous youtube videos claimed to show
evidence that such creatures exist
the bek also gained notoriety and lore
expansion through crowdfunded fan
fiction texts
and productions like sunshine girl and
the hunt for black-eyed kids
the black-eyed children and black eyed
children let me in
the comic series bek expands the
monster's threat with the invention of a
violent origin story
where regular children turn into
black-eyed kids if they murder their
family
bek are such great modern folklore
because they defy
romanticized notions of childhood and
the inherent goodness of children
ideas that have evolved over time the
perception of children as
innocent and weak requiring constant
adult instruction both morally and
physically
is a relatively modern invention prior
to the romantic period children were
largely
socially insignificant they were
background characters relegated to
chores familial duties and
little else but with the progression of
the industrial age in the late 18th
century
as infant mortality declined and
literature and philosophy regarding
child education grew
alongside increased scrutiny around
child labor the cultural concept of the
child
changed childhood became a sacred
cultural symbol
a time of perceived innocence and
happiness when children were not
valued for their usefulness or economic
viability
but rather for their hopeful possibility
and vulnerability
this view of childhood continued to
progress and evolve
well into the 20th century when the
seismic social shifts following world
war ii
changed everything suddenly youth
culture and scrutiny of popular media's
influence on children became
hot topics in 1950s pop culture was
flooded with movies and literature
showing bad kids and juvenile
delinquents
around this time the theme of children
being born evil
became a prevalent one as we were
introduced to ever younger characters
with genetically inherited threatening
characteristics
like a desire to kill and mind control
then through the 1970s and all the way
into the 90s we see a spike in horror
texts with children possessed by demons
or some
other kind of evil entity they're even
portrayed as the literal offspring of
satan
or the devil himself the rise of the
child villain can be framed in
countless ways including an emerging
fear of youth culture stemming from a
movement away from traditional
conservative ideas by younger
generations others argue it's a
manifestation of freud's oedipus complex
where it is the id the instinctual
unconscious part of the mind of the
child
that wants to murder the parent or peter
pan syndrome
which locates the child's desire to kill
in an attempt to reject their own future
as an adult
and sure as a generalized explanation
for the increase in fictional accounts
of terrifying children these all make
sense
but none of that really explains the
other key feature besides
age that makes the black eyed children
scary those black
eyes the eyes are the window to the soul
is a familiar saying
we communicate with our eyes and they
serve vital survival and social
functions
so when they appear unnaturally obscured
we become uncomfortable
even scared scientific research does
show that we tend to track the eye
movements of others as an evolutionary
social mechanism
perhaps the inability to follow the gaze
of the bek is what adds to their
eeriness
and the danger they threaten they could
be looking anywhere
or nowhere unfortunately this concept
was at one point taken to the extreme
with a practice called physionomy
which is predicated on the idea that
one's facial features and eyes could be
read as a natural language that would
reveal insight about a person's
character
or supposedly an indication of their
ethnic origins
needless to say there was a lot of
bigotry and racism in the practice
although its roots date back to ancient
chinese japanese and mesopotamian
traditions
the practice held prominent intellectual
weight in europe
until the 18th century unsurprisingly
the eyes were the most
important feature to interpret according
to a late 15th century text
eyes with no whites visible were
manifestations of
unreliability in a person there is also
a larger cultural history
of dark eyes or black eyes being tied to
inherent evilness
or an inner darkness including many
racist depictions of non-white
individuals and literature
including children dark or black eyes
are also featured in evocations of
possession and demonic presence
and often symbolize a lack of control to
me
black eyed children are the excuse the
pun offspring of four main
threads one our natural weariness of an
obscured or unusual gaze
two intergenerational conflict three the
legacy of malevolent children in horror
films
and four the ease of which the internet
reinforces urban legends
the power of the internet to expand the
reach of these creatures cannot be
overstated
historically folklore and folk tradition
have been passed on through generations
by word of mouth
and could even take years to spread from
one country or continent to the other
but in modern times the world wide web
functions as a global town square
the electronic equivalent of sharing
stories by the fire
i know that personally thanks to a
combination of the children of the corn
and the french film
them i am terrified of trick-or-treaters
which yes makes me somewhat of a
halloween grinch but it also helps me
understand why stories of bek continue
to circulate
obviously we know that my fear of
trick-or-treaters is largely irrational
and we know that there aren't soulless
children out there trying to kill us
right i mean the black-eyed kids are
always trying to breach the border from
outside to inside from a public space
with witnesses to a private more
solitary one
their faces are obscured their eyes
unreadable
this particular urban legend seems to
tap into something deeper
we are genetically programmed to care
for and protect the youngest of our
species for survival
so when they are portrayed as sinister
and dangerous it is deeply unsettling
the world of bek suggests that if you
care for children
they will kill you and if you ignore
them
they will haunt you
thank you to ancestry for supporting pbs
was that your great grandmother keeping
the family together
was that your great grandfather paving
the way for change did they brave mother
nature and walk away stronger
did they face the unknown with resolve
and triumph
there is strength in every family story
ancestry can help you learn about yours
visit ancestry.com for more information
it's not hard to figure out why they
will haunt you